There's still a lot of details on the page that you're going to need to
tweak before it looks exactly like the design mock up.
And you should continue to tweak to make this portfolio page your own.
At this point, it makes sense to get into the Code, Test, Refine process for
building your portfolio.
Code part of the portfolio.
Test your code by opening the page in the browser.
And then refine your code once you see what's right and what's wrong.
Then keep coding, keep testing, and keep refining.
My suggestion is to start off by making the layout look as much like the mock up
as possible, and once you're happy with the layout, start customizing it.
You can change the CSS or really, whatever you want.
Because this is your portfolio and it should show off you.
When you finish customizing, check this box to let us know that
you're happy with the way your portfolio looks.
Then, think back to the process of building the portfolio.
What was the hardest part for you?
Type your answer in here.
Good luck.
Jessica and I really can't wait to see your portfolios when you finish.